we're not gonna ask your Co we were set
to be Angela Andrew Luck was a unique
unique player but Jacoby Burr said is is
a winning football player in this league
and he is an app I think you here would
you what Andrew said Jacoby was said is
a rare rare leader he is he's a rare
human being man that that locker room
loves Jacoby percent we are ready to go
to battle and and we have tremendous
tremendous certainty that Jacoby is a
guy that can change this narrative I was
there when Bledsoe got hurt and Grady
came on the field who's a skinny guy
from Michigan I mean you know he was
there with the nick foles thing I mean
you know I can see Dick Vermeil crying
now you know and and look what happened
I mean it doesn't always happen but man
I mean that's the greatness of waking up
and being this game well that's a guy
who's trying to will himself to feel
better about a bad situation and who
knows yeah he preferred to Dick Vermeil
crying that was after Trent green had
his ACL torn preseason 1999 here comes
Kurt Warner who the helicopter he's the
MVP of the league yeah who the hell is
Tom Brady he's the greatest quarterback
of all time right so we're gonna find
out who Jacoby percent is but we've seen
plenty that's the difference we've seen
plenty of Jacoby Brissette he started 17
games in his NFL career he started 15
for the Colts right in 2017 when Andrew
Luck was out the shoulder but we've
given Brissette praise Chris because he
got thrust into that situation two years
ago Labor Day weekend traded straight up
for Phillip Dorsett and here's Jacoby
Brissette doesn't know the team doesn't
know the coaches doesn't know the office
doesn't know the city and he starts 15
games he only wins four but he played
well under the circumstances gets a full
offseason we can learn the offense they
build it around him and off they go
exactly right I mean this is a different
team than it was two years ago when he
was trying to
piece together a 15-game season and
figure out an offense on the fly and who
the heck are my teammates and I don't
even know who the right guard is you
know a few weeks later though that was a
big issue the biggest thing that jumps
out to me one jacobi per set has had a
lot of time and preseason football to
grow to like you said it's a new
coaching staff he's been in the system
for this this is a second year under
Frank Reich and three this team is a
different team than two years ago I mean
he's got he went from back then two
years ago to go this offensive line
shaky and this is the reason Andrew
Luck's out of football - now he's behind
the big blue ball you know it I mean
they are unreal it's one of the best
whole lines in football let alone they
got talent around them and and the
system and everything that goes with it
so again there are they gonna be as good
with Andrew Luck certainly not but do
they follow up Firth not at all I mean
Jacobi percent can do everything Andrew
Luck can maybe not to quite the you know
same capacity or the highest level but
it's still really good to make the
offense work and make a lot of big plays
and they're in very good hands with
Frank Reich the guy who fell out of the
sky after Josh McDaniels bailed on the
Colts following Super Bowl 52 Reich who
wasn't even a candidate before they
tentatively hired josh mcdaniels ends up
being the perfect guy for the job and he
came from philadelphia where they lost
carson wentz during December and still
won the Super Bowl with the backup
quarterback so the last guy to freak out
about this Kris is going to be frank
right right he's the perfect guy to take
this team forward and Chris Bal is the
perfect GM to continue to build and
refine and go and grow and I think that
yeah you scratch him off the list of
definite playoff team but I think that
when December rolls around they're still
gonna be alive yeah I wouldn't be in the
mix right maybe for the division
definitely for a wild-card berth and and
this is good for them because the
expectations now plummet yeah they fall
off the radar screen they can go about
their business almost like last year
when we expected nothing out of them
when they had Andrew Luck back because
we didn't expect anything out of luck
right same vibe now for the Colts in
29th the same type of vibe you're right
and you know I think the other thing too
that I always look at with a football
team to go
does it give you a chance I don't look
at the quarterback right away I look up
front and you know like we talked about
we know the old line special it's
arguably the best in football if not the
best
the defense is out of the ball there
front there I mean it's a pretty good
deep defensive line with a lot of young
talent to to so we're at least at the
very at the very least I look at it go
there's no team in football that's just
gonna overpower the Colts when they get
out in the field they're gonna be
totally mismatching we're gonna go oh
gosh and they had Andrew Luck here they
would win a shootout and they might be
able to pull this out no they're gonna
play any style of football they want
right now the way Chris Ballard has kind
of set up the football team they can do
it all they can play Smash Mouth they
can get in the shotgun rerp OS all you
want so again I do I think this team is
still dangerous I think the biggest area
they lose Andrew Luck in is one thing
and that's just a clutch factor Andrew
Luck was a little bit like a Derek Jeter
or a Tom Brady where you just don't you
agree
you were like Oh Colts are down by 10
with ten minutes left in the game Andrew
Luck will get the ball one time to win
the game at the end and more times than
not he came back made them come back or
they tied it or you know maybe squirt
away the other team scores late in the
game and they ended up losing but that's
where the greatness of Andrew Luck was I
think he always gave him a chance in the
fourth quarter to be competitive no
matter how crappy they might have played
the three quarters previous to that we
had the schedule up a minute ago and if
the control-room wants to put it back up
feel free to do put it up control
remember and there it is hey that was
quick
but here's the thing Chris let the firt
look at the first four games we get to
see them fry ourselves week five Sunday
night at the Chiefs but those first four
games Chargers Titans Falcons read it's
like if you're the opponents of the
Colts the first four weeks well how do
you regard them we talk all the time
about you know the teams that you get
fired up for the teams that you get
excited for the teams that have the
bull's eye when you if you're getting
ready for the Colts no they're not have
Andrew Luck I don't care what the coach
says in there right you know you're
gonna think they're nothing without
Andrew Luck lately you know they may
catch some people off-guard here and
they could be three in one oh there's a
pretty reverse Jedi mind-trick to the
bullets as far as the NFL is concerned
because you're right opposing teams are
gonna look at the Colts and go we feel
better now Jacoby Presets not there the
Colts are gonna be in the locker room go
we could still win games without Andrew
Luck you know screw Andrew luck we can
he's not the whole team and I mean that
respectfully Andrew Luck but that's just
a mentality of a guy at a locker room
where they're gonna go
not one guy makes our football game
think screw certain name can never be
used respect football wise it can be
screwed
but regardless yeah I don't think this
is a team that that is gonna fall apart
there's great leadership at all levels
here I mean Jim Irsay hey has he had
some wild moments in his life certainly
but he loves his team he loves his
players Chris Ballard same way I mean
Frank Reich you mentioned it so there's
tremendous leadership throughout the
football team to where I just think this
team is still gonna be highly
competitive and fun to watch I feel
pretty good about the culture yeah yeah
it's a big decisions to make that I
think I've heard they're already talking
about trying to extend you Cobre sets
contract which they should do the right
situations looking really good really
with Chad Kelly behind him who has a
chance to be he's really special but I
understand jacobi percent getting
extended so nobody's dreamed a year
after everything that Chad Kelly went
through he's gonna be back in position
to be a number two quarterback
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports